[Music]
Ginni Rometty is the CEO of IBM said she
believed that blockchain technology will
be to transactions what the internet was
to information right meaning it'll be
pervasive across all industries that
touch transactions which is all of them
right they all deal with money they all
deal with tracking of product and the
handoffs of value from one party to
another right so unless you're in a
business that does nothing of value at
some point blockchain technology will
touch what you're doing right and in
some for some businesses it'll radically
transform who they are and what they do
one of the most intriguing use cases
that really caught my attention when I
first started to dive into this this
technology landscape was the use of
distributed Ledger's for supply chain
provenance partly as a way to make that
industry more more more efficient more
collaborative more transparent but also
as a way to try to fight or track where
objects came from and make sure they
came from the right places and a great
example of this is the diamond industry
the diamond industry starting about 20
years ago has had a real serious
political top-down commitment to prevent
blood diamonds from entering circulation
right blood diamonds being diamonds that
came from mines that involve slave labor
that perhaps were used as payment for
illicit products and services right like
these are diamonds that that had unclear
provenance and the whole goal was to
enable somebody buying a diamond at the
retail channel to know all the way back
to the mine that it came from and that
between it points a and B it was in good
hands right right now when you try to
buy a diamond and see that provenance
you maybe get a certificate with a bunch
of stamps on it but what does that mean
to you right what does that mean to
anybody so the diamond industry is
realized that they need to transform
that process into something that was
more of a distributed ledger in fact is
an implementation of a distributed
ledger as a way to allow all the parties
involved in the diamond process to
record a transaction every time that
they transfer diamonds from the mine to
the refinery to like the place where
it's worked on to the distributor out to
the retail channel each of those parties
would be
participant on that ledger and when they
handed diamonds off they or they
received a package of diamonds would
confirm and write transactions saying I
sent this I received this so that we
have this unbreakable chain going all
the way back to the mine of where these
diamonds came from and and we can deal
with parties who themselves might not
have a long history a deep history of
involvement but if they have these
digital signatures which would be really
difficult if not impossible to forge
right then they could participate and be
a part of this process and we might
eventually get to a model that looks
somewhat like when you buy a car you
register that car in a title system
right that if your car gets stolen right
you can go and say well no actually I
own that or if somebody tried to steal
your car and sell it somebody else
without your consent that you know that
that's tracked by the titles title
system right will probably get to a
point where your ability to sell a
diamond of certain expense or quality or
higher it is based on being able to show
that your ownership is recorded in this
in this ledger all right which would do
a tremendous amount to try to keep a bad
product from entering the market that I
think would do a lot to us to help
reinforce the trust in that market and
by the way it might create a marketplace
for whistleblowing
right some factories for example that
employ a lot of human labor they try to
ensure that the temperature inside these
factories remains at a certain
temperature you know in a certain
certain temperature range right and so
if you had sensors collecting that data
and tracking along with the product that
comes through right so you understood
okay this is this is a product that was
made in an environment that was meets
all of our criteria for the creation of
these products right a situation where a
factory collapsed in Bangladesh that was
being used to manufacture many of the
brands that you see today at any major
department store and this was not only a
tree disaster in that hundreds of people
perished but also an economic disaster
for the brands that whose products were
there and the suppliers who are bringing
that product forward because there is a
clear sense that many of these brands
like the gap who did invest quite a bit
in trying to upgrade their source or the
sources of supply to come
from high-quality manufacturers to come
from people who cared about working
conditions who cared about labor labor
raising the floor raising the standards
for labor and their Mahr in their in
their industries many of them had no
idea where their products actually were
coming from many of these brands had
very little idea so in the textile and
clothing industry there's been a
tremendous push to upgrade their supply
chains to try to reward manufacturers in
countries like Bangladesh or Thailand or
India or even here in the US
reward them for improving their labor
standards improving the quality of
manufacturing and and paying them extra
for it the problem is when it's easy for
somebody to slip in product into that
supply chain without all of that quality
control without that extra concern then
it hurts everybody right it hurts those
manufacturers who've invested more to
actually to create higher quality
products and a better story behind the
sourcing of that product so they're a
distributed ledger would be really
helpful to try to understand you know
where are these products coming from
where the where the source is coming
from that sort of thing the other use
case that's really intriguing to me is
seafood so they're you know we had
there's there's an plenty of
international systems out there that
track the quotas and and the allowed
caches and allowed regions for for fish
right different species of fish there's
practically an international
organization for each species it seems
right and these are there's rules that
that tell fisheries where they are
fishermen where they're allowed to catch
and which countries are allowed to
ingest those catches and then package
them and ship them out and no surprise
there's a tremendous amount of piracy
there's a tremendous amount of illegal
fish catching there's a tremendous
amount of one kind of fish being passed
off as another kind and and so and then
making its way through the supply chain
a tremendous amount of fraud that's
added to it as it as attended off and
finally ends up on your plate if you
ordered sea bass chances are it's not
actually sea bass in front of you right
and chances are it was possible it was
caught somewhere illegally rather than
in the allowed areas so that industry is
now starting to also take a look at how
do we use block chains distributed
ledger technologies
to make the provenance tracking of that
system much more airtight right so that
we know where it comes from we know who
it's been handed off to and more
importantly how do we add sensor data
from IOT devices right that say tamper
proof GPS tracking data collection
devices on the boats themselves right to
sensor data from ports that see when
boats come in to satellite data that can
track and see at high enough resolution
when the boats are coming and going all
right all of this data put together to
try to say here's the formal provenance
record and here's all the sensor data
that corroborates all that and by the
way here's a place where the all the
data doesn't line up and we might want
to look more closely at that and see if
some fraud happened there all of this
for the purpose of making sure that we
have sustainable fisheries in the ocean
and to make sure the product you buy
when it says you know sustainably caught
or wild salmon or whatever is actually
the product that you're buying
[Music]